[Music]
frustrated um
a little embarrassed you know we we
didn't show up we didn't show up they
beat the crap out of us and uh we got to
be better but like i said i'm confident
that we'll get things fixed um you know
this is a this is a ticked off group
we're gonna we're gonna rebound from it
and you know i'm confident we'll be all
right
carson wentz after the 37-10 loss to the
cowboys on sunday night the group is
ticked off they're ticked off not just
about the outcome on the field lane
johnson is ticked off about
accountability issues chris this came
from nbc sports philadelphia in the
aftermath of the game johnson believes
that the next team meeting will include
a call out session where everyone will
be held accountable little stuff that
slides during the week late to practice
late to meetings late this late that
stuff will start to be held accountable
for and maybe that'll creep into the
games and that's all well and good the
problem is malcolm jenkins eagle safety
says i'm not aware of any issue with
people being late so they don't they may
they either have accountability problem
or they have a problem figuring out
whether they have an accountability
problem either way doug peterson the
coach the team needs to get this under
control either guys are showing up late
or he's got guys who think they're
showing up late and it's starting to
fracture and fall apart and they're
three and four and and i think this is
gonna be the toughest test of peterson's
years with the team to try to get a team
that had high expectations back on the
same page quickly or they're going to
slide right out of playoff contention
yeah they're in trouble there there's no
question about that and you know injury
is where it all started i mean they've
lost a lot of players injury this year
they're a banged-up football team so
that's their biggest issue but hey when
you start to lose football games and
have the expectations that you talk
about and you're a super bowl contender
and now okay yes you're three and four
you know guys like lane johnson they've
noticed maybe some things during the
last few weeks that you know and it's
it's perfectly like logical to where one
guy notices things that he thinks need
to be buttoned up and another guy you
know is maybe not paying attention to
those little things you know you can be
sitting in a team meeting just for an
instance mike and just just to give an
example okay it's at eight o'clock in
the morning team meeting we're all in
there most of the guys are in there you
know lane johnson could be one of those
guys that looks in and goes man you know
i always see these few players kind of
straggle in at 801 or you know eight
eight minutes and 30 seconds and maybe
doug peterson's not in front of the room
yet talking so the meeting hasn't
started but you know he's an offensive
lineman maybe he doesn't like that while
malcolm jenkins can be in the back of
the room talking to the dbs or whatever
and not even realizing that there's guys
straggling in late so it could be simple
as that as far as the differences of why
one guy sees it one way and another one
doesn't know exactly what the guy is
talking about
do you think things like that do
manifest themselves in wins and losses i
mean not not guys blowing in 15 minutes
late or not coming to meetings
whatsoever but just little details like
that guys straggling in yes does that
become an issue in practice and more
importantly on game day i i do think it
does i think it eventually does filter
down to what is done in meeting rooms in
the field and things like that you know
what lane johnson could be referring to
hey we have an offensive line meeting
you know after practice every day at 4
30 and you know a lot of guys are
walking in at 4 33 4 35 whatever it may
be and he might be pissed off about that
too you know and yes they i you know oh
this is five more minutes we could add a
little more detail about something or a
certain subject uh i do think that can
filter down to the details of what's
done in meeting rooms and and the play
on the field
yeah and look i i look back at their
schedule this year they were down 17
nothing to washington they came back and
won in large part because desean jackson
had a huge
debut in his return to the eagles now he
hasn't played since then he may have
played just a very little bit against
the falcons but had no
receptions in that game they haven't
been the same offense without him no
they somehow beat the packers that's the
one game that really stands out and then
they thumped the jets but they've lost
38 to 20 and
to 10 the last two weeks i mean it has
quickly fallen apart for the
philadelphia eagles they have to go to
buffalo it's that three game road trip
that they embarked on and it has been a
disaster so far for the philadelphia
eagles chris yeah i mean offensive line
issues there's they've been banged up
there you sh you said it desean jackson
that was huge there's no playmakers on
the who are you scared of on the eagles
offense right now who's there to be
scared of other than carson wentz
breaking seven tackles to throw a ball
and then get killed as he's throwing it
i mean that's the only thing that goes
on in the offense the defense you know
you lose uh um you know malik jackson
who they gave a lot of money to you know
jernigan's hurt avonte maddox is hurt
ronald darby's hurt you just start to go
through it they got a lot of big
injuries at big positions and it's it's
hurting their team
yeah and uh they've got to turn it
around quickly because only one team out
of that division is getting to the
playoffs and right now it's the cowboys
with the one game lead plus the
tiebreaker by virtue of beating the
eagles on sunday night we're gonna take
a quick break peter king will join us
for the final out of the program we'll
be back with that right after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports